monsieur sur les rives de la rivière
madame à fort-de-france pour vous
présenter un projet d'art dans là ville
quand ils étaient reliés au fort ce
canal et le centre culturel et
économique de la ville mais il est
délaissé depuis longtemps malgré les
nombreux commerces tout le monde pour
notre envie lui redonner ses lettres de
noblesse en colorant la ville avec
l'aide des habitants
notre idée est de réhabiliter cet axe
urbain en créant un véritable parcours
artistique et paysager ex pour cela nous
allons réaliser une fresque monumentale
depuis six ans est en faisant appel à
des artistes locaux ce projet aura
également un intérêt pédagogique car
nous allons réaliser des ateliers
artistiques dans cinq établissements
scolaires ni belle madame du plus qu'un
projet artistique
c'est un projet participatif qui a pour
but de redynamiser et en binaire le
centre ville nous souhaitons que les
martiniquais se réapproprient leur ville
et que les visiteurs du monde entier
découvrent la culture et l'art antique
allez cliquer
[Musique]